[Music]
all right
all over the nation in several states
people are receiving you say that in a
jamaican accent
no nation nope
but then and they kind of morphed into
kind of jamaica
i gotta watch cool runnings again true
true we just watched it like last week
oh that's wow
it's fresh so good oh you say it and you
let me hear your jamaicans oh yeah what
the hell you said
i only like getting other people in
trouble okay
all right so all over the nation uh
there are
mysterious packages uh being received by
just random people uh from china
if there's money in that i'd give it
i'll take it i don't know what the
the actual value of the contents of the
packages
are well it's seeds so inside the
packages
seeds like plant seeds but do we know
what kind of
seeds like chinese pine trees you know
what
the experts don't even know what's going
on with these packages
like like everyone's receiving it it's
all like uh
seeds inside on the outside the package
they're saying
like oh uh earrings jewelry it's like
they say it's one thing on the outside
but once they open it it's like
it's all plants yeah whoa and it's from
coming from china
and so then this guy is this chinese
warfare
i don't know and that's what people are
saying they're hoping that people will
start planning it
around this well what is it they're like
they're like it's like poison ivy and it
just takes
over your whole house maybe and then you
die because it's kind of like
i was thinking it was just like poppy
seeds and then you grow opium
maybe it's some kind of seeds that if
you plant them then it'll [ __ ] up with
our agriculture somehow
and then like screw this whole thing and
that's what the u.s government is saying
it's like hey do not plant these things
uh why would anyone plant a random
[ __ ] seed
they're just hoping that one person well
doyle crenshawn
from uh arkansas oh my god doyle invited
to plant bee seeds and that's doyle's
garden
after the seeds that he those are the
these are the seeds he planted yeah
and he planted it two months ago so
right now currently they're trying to
confiscate all these seeds
and they've gotten in contact with doyle
now and they're gonna
basically dig up this plant we did that
um
did he like publicize that like hey i
got these seeds from china and check out
the plant i don't know he's like
vlogging
he's like vlogging he has a youtube
channel
he's going viral over china crenshawn
what blows my mind is like you get a
package from a foreign country right you
don't even know anyone from that country
you open it up
and then you go oh seeds let me plant
them like who thinks that
yeah well maybe it was really sweet yeah
that is kind of dumb is that a radish
what the [ __ ] is it people don't know
people are watching yeah people are
calling her squash there's like the
winter melon no the
anal beast oh what is that
the thing that he was talking about
earlier where the doctor was giving him
a pill through his butt oh
this thing looks like it's like this big
though yeah yeah it looks huge
gigantic squash or something yeah that's
that's the fruit it bears
and then this is the flower that it
bears so it might be some poison [ __ ]
or whatever who knows why did this guy
plan it
i don't know agricultural experts can't
decide on what oh you want to make it
better
they don't they can't decide on what it
is they don't they haven't figured it
out yet or at least they haven't
published it yet they i mean they can
make it bigger be like it's kind of a
melon because it it looks like some [ __ ]
we've seen before
true true i thought it was gonna be like
bitter melon or something
like some chinese [ __ ] i know right yeah
wait so how do they
not know what it is at all like they're
confiscating that i don't think they're
probably not publishing it they're
probably not saying what it is they've
probably identified
yeah they probably know already yeah but
um
but uh doyle is a character though i
have a little mini clip of doyle here
not every two weeks i'd come by and put
miracle grill on
and they just start growing crazy lived
in booneville uh
china and it said studded earrings on
the outside package
we thought that was a little odd i was
that's the kind of guy that would
that would grow in that's a little i'll
just play him anyways who cares
he looks like a curious man come out he
looks happy look at this i know
he's just like i'm just happy to plant
them and see what happens
golf cart like that i'd be happy too i
want one have you guys ever
rode a gator huh wait what
a gator what's a gator uh an alley it's
kind of like a
no no it's kind of it's a it's kind of
like a golf cart but off road oh
then i want a gator gators are [ __ ]
fun wait is it kind of open
in the thing yeah it's like a golf cart
but it's like an off-road golf cart
i think i was in one of those those are
fun and then you can have like a little
trailer or whatever oh fun i'd be happy
what a freaking guy man yeah so
basically the
the the arkansas department of
agriculture has gone in contact with
uh with uh doyle here and they're
basically
concerned that it might be an invasive
pest aspect
the seeds could introduce an invasive
weed or invasive uh
insect pest or plant disease so they're
saying not to plant these things
how are you finding just random people
to send it to
uh and and then the white house police
department um
is saying that this might be a brushing
scam
and what a brushing scam is is i just
lost it where to go
brushing scam it is a uh a way to
exploit by vendor using a product
sending it to people to use and then
they actually use
uh that person's like oh let me restate
this again okay
so a brushing scam is an exploit by a
vendor used to bolster product ratings
and increase
visibility online by shipping an
inexpensive product to an unwitting
receiver
and then submitting positive reviews on
the receiver's behalf
under the guise of a verified owner but
that sounds like it would make sense
if they were actually earrings in that
package but the fact that these are
seeds
that doesn't even make sense well it
could just be empty package materials
true maybe so maybe they just
threw in like seeds because it's like
not that valuable but it's something to
send i don't know
but that goes against the whole goal of
marketing true the whole goal of
marketing
and the product increased exposure
there's no no the way that they're doing
it is this
so like let's say i make a fake account
on ebay
right and my address i just need an
american address to send
you randomly get picked we send this
package to your address now my account
is verified that it's sent or it
received
a package now i can put a review
five-star review these earrings were
amazing
that's the stamp damn that's [ __ ]
smart if that's what they're doing yeah
but then
why put seeds in there that's what i
don't get
like it's probably anything it could be
a box full of [ __ ]
paper yeah styrofoam peanuts yeah
because you still have to buy
the ziploc bags and put seeds in it and
sort them and put different seeds like
yeah that's why it seems like it's more
malicious than just
to bolster up their roots like it's
warfare or something i think is [ __ ]
some sort of biological warfare
yeah we got killer melons happening yeah
and they take over all of our
agriculture you know what's funny is
that
we have these agriculture experts that
don't know what the [ __ ] it is
but it's probably because they're like
arkansas and they're only used to like
corn and potato and [ __ ] they don't know
these asian
asian vegetables all the white corn they
named potato
i think they've identified it i feel
like they know what it is but the allure
of it still remaining a mystery
casts more of like a dangerous aspect to
it to the point where
it really scares people into genuinely
not planting
these seeds i think that's what they do
right and then and then kind of planting
this
this idea that china is the enemy rather
than i don't know about that i really
don't know
what the end goal here is on from either
end but i think
it would be smart of like like if our
goal is to
stop our citizens from planting these
mystery seeds i think it's smart
to like one identify what the plant is
and then
withhold that information to create this
scarier
idea of like oh my gosh don't plant it
unless if it's like if you say oh it's
just squash
chinese squash and they'll be like oh
let me try it yeah and thank you
and they're like hey we identified these
mystery seeds and they're just like
tomatoes like
people be planting them right yeah
they're like i want to see free seeds
or maybe like yeah they'll just like
toss them out if they don't want them
and then they'll end up growing
maybe these people maybe the cops want
them to just like properly dispose of
them
don't do anything like that just throw
them in the trash bowl shoots
yeah i wish it was like some chinese
plants
let me tell you something like rare [ __ ]
right
that should just look like winter melon
i know it does it seems like they're
sending different uh
uh seeds though because then the one
that doyle planted were white
and then these ones kind of maybe that's
why they're saying what don't
plant them because who knows what seeds
people got
because it seems like they're getting
different ones or imagine
the the chinese fbi was like
or the cia or whatever they're like how
can we [ __ ] up america today
and then they go hmm we tried social
media you know tried their election
let's do killer squash let's do it
look but how are we going to get them to
plan it just send it out there americans
are dumb
right so true so true yeah and so
at least 27 states have received these
kinds of 267
states yeah and they've included
washington colorado
kentucky nevada and texas nevada
nevada no i like nobody nevada i feel
like there's got to be some americans
out there that are like we better send
some goddamn seeds back over there
[ __ ] them up well what kind of american
season we're going to send over there
spike em up over there
imagine you go to china's [ __ ] cactus
all over the place
that look crazy like they get a package
they're like what are you going to do
with this one
i don't know plant it yeah they'll
probably do it over there too
frustrating plants at this
supposed to be a war becomes like it's
all the [ __ ] the two countries that
unifies to become all happy now
but like with plants friends through
gardening
so the usda animal and plant health
inspection
service anti-smuggling hotline is
1-800-877-3835
if you indeed have received a package so
i don't know
smuggling seeds i would have [ __ ]
planted and ate it
and ate it oh [ __ ] that's scary make a
soup out of it
yup i probably would have planted it
just because i'm curious
but it looks like a vegetable though it
looks really edible though yeah it
doesn't look like
looks like it'll be a good soup or maybe
i could just get a chinese grandma to
come identify it and she's like oh
that's easy
and then all these [ __ ] scientists
were like what
how did she just know what it was she
smells it i don't
if you ever go to the asian market
though their diversity in the [ __ ]
produce section is like i don't even
know how to cook
90 of that [ __ ] i'm looking at it like
you're telling me that the [ __ ] leafy
part of the radish could have been eaten
and you go over here you're like you're
telling me the carrot part well the top
could have been eaten like
you guys are eating things that i didn't
even know was possible that's true yeah
you know what growing up with my mom
cooking and then
and then like later learning how to cook
like american food i
i reverse learned it because then i was
like dude american cooking wastes
a lot of things like the parts of
animals and like
even like when you cut up an uh a green
onion it's like they only use like
the the the white part and then the
green parts they discard
are you serious they do scallions
scallions yeah green onions
they do use that same thing green part
no uh
no a lot of people discard it because
like they say most of the flavor is in
the white part
so you keep the white part and the green
like the really really green part the
top part
true but even with like broccoli you
know like you cut the whole stock off
because people just want to eat florets
oh yeah but then a lot of asian cooking
like you cut up the stock and you just
chop it up smaller and just break it in
that's so true i prefer the stock it's
crunchier because like the florets have
a weird texture it's like eating a
mouthful of dust
right so this stock is too bitter for me
that's why i like the leaf oh yeah
i'm cool my favorite is brocco
broccolini though broccoli it's too
exciting
fancy man yeah it's like i'm sorry i'm
fancy
it tastes better true it's easier to
cook too it's thinner it cooks
more evenly that's one of those
vegetables though where if you bust it
out like out of your tupperware i'd be
like what you think you're better than
me i'm broccolini is that diet food
yeah right yeah that's true every time i
see broccolini with some steak i'm like
oh you've been oh brooklyn what are you
the queen of england i know
who gets broccolini hello guys thank you
guys so much for watching all of our
videos and i know it's been a million
years
in the making but we finally got just
kidding news
merch yeah so make sure you go down to
the store below
and you can run around yeah you can get
a piece
of jk news and thank you guys for
supporting thank you
[Music]
bye-bye
so